traumatisé par la première vague de
l'épidémie l'italie tente de maîtriser
la seconde alors la péninsule se re
confine avec des différences en fonction
des régions
trois d'entre elles sont mises sur liste
rouge la lombardie la sicile et les eaux
haut-adige dans ces territoires
les déplacements non justifiées sont
maintenant interdits et les commerces
non essentiels resteront fermés à rome
le confinement est moins stricte mais
les mesures se durcissent alors qu'ils
étaient jusque-là ouvert les bars et les
restaurants n'ont désormais plus le
choix ils doivent se limiter à la vente
à emporter un drame pour ce propriétaire
c'est très difficile pour nous à partir
de demain 28 de nos employés resteront
chez eux sans oublier nos contrats
courts qui eux aussi resteront chez eux
pour nous c'est vraiment très difficile
en ce moment mais certains ont décidé de
désobéir
dans plusieurs régions des restaurateurs
ont défié les autorités aient ouvert le
restaurant parfois soutenues par les
clients
les restrictions qu'ils en pause avec
cette soi-disant urgences ne détruise
tout ça sicaud logiquement et
économiquement donc ce monsieur qui ait
le courage d'ouvrir son restaurant a
besoin d'être soutenue par les gens et
c'est pourquoi nous sommes venus nous
sommes très heureux d'apporter notre
soutien ce restaurateur parce qu'à notre
avis des mesures qui ont été prises pour
arrêter la propagation du virus pour la
prévenir sont exagérées face à la fronde
les policiers ont patrouillé et
distribuer des amendes les nouvelles
mesures sont en place jusqu'au 15
février minimum alors que le pays
poursuit sa campagne de vaccination hier
le chiffre d'un million d'italiens
vaccinées étaient dépassées